un matin nous allons prier dans cette
synagogue de la rue copernic demain
matin et la semaine prochaine et toute
la semaine et pour toujours
nous n'avons pas peur
3 octobre 1980 il y à 40 ans un attentat
à la bombe visant une synagogue rue
copernic à paris
le premier attentat contre des juifs en
france depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale bilan 4 morts et 46
blessés le jour même la principale
association de lutte contre le racisme
accuse d'extrême droite
si la bombe avait éclaté une demi-heure
plus tard comme sans doute ch était
prévu nous aurions sens où 200 morts
wohlen munich et ce soir paris j'accuse
de l'international nagy d'organiser ces
attentats criminels effectivement
l'enquêté s'oriente vers un groupe
d'extrême droite
la fan pourtant 10 ou quelques semaines
avant l'attentât
mais cette piste ne donne rien l'enquète
s'enlise loket sur l'attentât de la rue
copernic n'a donc pas beaucoup progressé
aujourd'hui 1981
les investigations avancent très
lentement une nouvelle piste est creusé
celle d'une moto garée sur le lieu de
l'attentât
les enquêteurs réussissent à identifier
son propriétaire
cette fois un suspect identifié ont
réussi à former le premier portrait
robot de l'auteur l'attentât vous le
connaissez cet homme se fait appeler
panadriyu et il est muni d'un passeport
chypriote
c'est une impasse le passeport est le
nom sont faux impossible de retrouver le
suspect pendant des années
l'enquète ne donne rien il faut attendre
2007 pour qu'elle soit relancé 27 ans
après l'auteur présumé de l'attentât
contre la synagogue de la rue copernic à
paris a été repéré par la police
française
cet auteur présumé c'est hassan diab ce
professeur libano canadien de 53 ans
serait l'homme du portrait-robot
soupçonné d'avoir fabriqué la bombe
il aurait aussi été membre du fplp os un
groupe né du front populaire de
libération de la palestine en 2008 il
est arrêté au canada et dans la
communauté juive leur et de soulagement
mieux vaut tard que jamais pendant 28
ans léger mieux dans quel policière au
moins page pas chez nous jusqu'il ya
quelques mois hassan diab est extradé
vers la france en 2014 puis mis en
examen en 2018 il bénéficie d'un
non-lieu faute de charges suffisantes
aujourd'hui quarante ans après
l'attentât aucun autre suspect n'a été
arrêté
[Musique]